zwei Geheimnisse wird der Graf jetzt im
frankenlotto preisgeben und zwar wird er
sich noch mal seine Fingernägel
lackieren und wird es noch mal eine
bildhome Story bei ihm geben und mich
wird interessieren was er zum Thema sagt
ist der Graf inzwischen arrogant
geworden bitte in die Kommentare
schreiben bis dann bleibt dran
ja endlich komm mal die bösen Fragen
jetzt kommen die richtig böse ehrlich
die richtig böse gemeint
das ist schwer gemeint hinterhältig wir
haben uns seine schwachen Seiten
hoffentlich haben sie gefunden die
Leichen im Keller die Leichen und ja
Freunde
wann trägst du wieder
vampirkontaktlinsen und lackierst dir
deine Fingernägel nie mehr warum nicht
war doch so schön das einfach das ist
nicht mehr für mich persönlich nicht
mehr zeitgemäß das habe ich damals
gemacht weil es gut fand und weil ich
die Kontaktlinsen habe ich getragen um
mich dahinter zu verstecken weil schon
doch sehr schüchtern bin und die
Fingernägel habe ich mir lackiert weil
ich dachte es sieht cool aus aber wenn
die immer wieder abplatzen und wenn dann
einfach nicht gut ist und das sieht doof
aus und jeden Morgen sitzt du da
wirklich in deinem Hotelzimmer und bist
ja die Fingernägel am machen und alle
stehen schon unten und du stehst dann da
oben ich komme gleich Moment komm gleich
und dann sind die Dinge trocken und dann
nimmst du deinen Koffer und dann und
dann sehen die wieder so aus ey und nur
um dann zu zeigen hier ja ich komme aus
der Gothic Szene ich trage schwarze
Fingernägel
kann ich auch so dass es eine Sache des
Herzens und nicht das Aussehens und die
Kontaktlinsen da bin ich auch froh dass
ich die nicht mehr trage weil es einfach
heutzutage für mich nicht mehr nicht
mehr in Frage käme weil ich es nicht
mehr gut finde ich trage heutzutage auch
nicht die Klamotten die ich in den 80er
Jahren an hatte auch wenn es manche
Leute wahrscheinlich sehr unterhalten
würde da habe ich mich dann doch
weiterentwickelt und sage mir einfach
Nein Danke dass war mal war auch gut
damals aber seit 2006 nicht mehr haben
dir das Fans denn übel genommen oder
sind die mit rausgewachsen ich weiß
nicht also ich kenne ganze Menge Fans
die den Weg von Unheilig komplett
mitgehen es gibt aber eine ganze Menge
Fans die sagen hey das ist nicht unsere
unsere also dieses all das was da jetzt
passiert ist nicht etwas für uns das
akzeptiere ich aber mein Spiegel und
mein
das was mir wichtig ist sehe ich wenn
ich die Menschen zum Beispiel bei den
Autogrammstunden sehe da habe ich sie
direkt vorm vor mir und das sind immer
noch ganz viele von den Leuten bei die
schon vor acht Jahren kennengelernt habe
und da freue ich mich riesig drüber und
wieder total stolz drauf dass die den
Weg mitgehen dass die wirklich sagen wir
kommen aus der Szene und wir gehen den
Weg trotzdem mit auch wenn du er voll
hast und wenn auch Leute deinem Musik
hören die jetzt gerade nichts mit der
Szene etwas zu tun haben zum Beispiel
das ist eine Sache des Respektes und der
Toleranz die man selber erwartet von
anderen die kannst du nur kriegen wenn
du selber respektvoll und Toleranz bist
tolerant bist es ändert sich ja nichts
dadurch die Musik ist nicht anders
geworden auf dem auf der Platte auf der
Platte Phosphor gibt das heißt stark
wenn ich das jetzt veröffentlichen würde
würden sie auch alle meine Schreiben
Kommerz aber dabei ist das Lied schon 12
Jahre alt also ich habe meine Musik
nicht geändert sie hat sich höchstens
weiterentwickelt und ich habe damit kein
Problem und ich ich genieße das jetzt
und daher werde ich keine weißen
Kontaktlinsen mehr anziehen und das ist
nicht mehr meins schade
nein Quatsch nein ich sehe dir gerne die
Augen zum Beispiel immer weißt wie
unangenehm das ist wenn du diese
Kontaktlinsen an hast die Leute für dein
Gegenüber
der sitzt die ganze Zeit so da
ja
ich will das ja ich liebe das ja also
Konfrontation Reibung ja das sind ja
okay Wärme
ganz ernstes Thema warum bist du so
arrogant geworden
ich weiß nicht ich also ich habe das
Gefühl dass ich nicht arrogant bin
dass die Leute quasi so eine Zeit
voneinander erfolgreich
zum Beispiel ein Autogrammstunden kannst
ja wirklich nicht mehr alle allen
Autogramme 14 bis 22 Uhr hast du da
gesehen also wir haben jetzt vier Tage
Autogrammstunden gegeben und insgesamt
waren es 32 Stunden die ich in vier
Tagen da gestanden habe
wenn einer glaubt ich bin arrogant wenn
ich nach 8 Stunden Autogramme endlich
dann irgendwann sage Freunde ich kann
nicht mehr ich bin jetzt mal völlig leer
dem kann ich leider auch nicht mehr
helfen okay also ich versuche gerade den
Menschen zu zeigen durch diese Nähe dass
ich ein ganz normaler Typ bin ich im
Fernsehen zu sehen ich kann es ja im
Radio hören aber ich bin trotzdem der
gleiche Mensch wie auch früher da lege
ich total drauf und wenn irgendjemand
aus meiner Familie zu mir sagen würde
mein Freund du bist aber ganz schön
arrogant geworden dann gehen bei mir die
Alarm ich glaube schon dass mein Umfeld
so klar ist dass ich genau weiß wenn
irgendwas in dieser Art und Weise
passieren sollte was ich selber nicht so
merke
okay da habe ich schon meine Leute die
mir da auch in den Nacken hauen und das
ist auch gut so gerade Familie ist da
total wichtig also da den kann ich
nichts vormachen also die wissen ganz
genau weil jetzt ist aber hier ne also
kostet Wasser oder aber ich habe ehrlich
gesagt das ist das allererste Mal dass
einer wirklich zu mir oder mich fragen
würde warum bist du so arrogant geworden
da würde ich erstmal sagen echt also ich
würde trotzdem die Frage stellen immer
Unterstellung muss ich dir um dich zu
beruhigen das ist
ja natürlich nein weil ich mir
vorstellen kann weil du hast ja gesagt
du hast das war immer dein Ziel wirklich
jedem Fan immer ja du begegnen und jetzt
geht genau ja aber das ist das Problem
also ich habe meine Autogrammstunde
gegeben beim Zita Rockfestival in Berlin
heißt hieß das glaube ich genau vom
Auftritt hatten wir eine oder zwei
Stunden ich habe da ich habe da dann
also insgesamt
vier Stunden raus gemacht aber die
schlagen aber immer noch lang und ich
schaue so musste gehen weil ich einen
Auftritt hatte und ja also bin ich schon
beschimpft worden von Leuten die da
schon seit drei Stunden stehen und jetzt
geht da der Punkt Punkt Punkt Punkt da
sie mir Sachen an den Kopf geschmissen
worden wo ich dann auch gedacht habe
Freunde soll ich jetzt hier nur
Autogramme geben oder soll ich mir oder
solchen Konzert machen und irgendwann
geht das nicht mehr ein bisschen
Größenordnung und wenn einer glaubt dann
ist er arrogant wenn er jetzt nicht mehr
zu mir kommt dann ist das eine falsche
Information weil ich bin immer der
Mensch der auch zwei Jahre lang alles
dafür versucht hat zu machen den Leuten
wieder dann wieder nah zu sein sei
seines z.B die ganzen witziges gewesen
wir haben ja versucht diese große
Menschenmenge irgendwie so zu
verkleinern dass ich wieder zu den
Leuten kann aber der Schlüssel ist
eigentlich der lange im Voraus
autogrammstundenplan
wo du kein Konzert vorher hast oder
nachher dass du wirklich mal acht
Stunden lang da in aller Ruhe ohne
Hektik und nicht wie am Fließband auch
mal jeden mal Herzen kannst Fotos machen
kannst die dir was geben können das war
die letzten vier Tage super und das hat
mir persönlich eine ganze Menge gebracht
und du kriegst keinen keinen äh Kampf im
Arm im Arm nicht aber in den Füßen ne
also die Fußknöchel sind so bei mir ich
bin ja so ein kleines äh so ein kleines
zierliches Männchen eher ich habe ja so
ganz schmale Handgelenke im Gegensatz zu
dir sind meine Handgelenke du hast ja ja
der Künstler und dem Mensch sprechen
schmal sind auch meine Fußknöchel und da
tut's dann nach sechs bis sieben acht
Stunden schon weh wurde denkst jetzt
musst du dich mal drehen jetzt muss dann
knackt es auch so okay okay aber das ist
okay unterschreiben könnte ich immer
noch
gut noch eine letzte Frage ja auch noch
rot oder immer rot okay ich finde die
negativen super und ja dann oder willst
auch ich finde die negativ auch schön
ich Ärger gerne Leute aber ich hoffe es
kommt drüber freundschaftlich und nett
und ja
ich lese das mal vor du kennst Christoph
jetzt schon so lange jetzt kannst du ihm
doch endlich mal sagen wie du heißt oder
das mache ich gerne wenn die Kameras
Aussehen okay
wenn er wirklich nichts mehr hat wo er
was aufnimmt oder so ja also das ist bei
mir eine Sache von der Öffentlichkeit
Privatleben ist privat ne da kannst du
mir auch alles Geld der Welt bieten ich
würde meinen privaten Leben nie in die
Öffentlichkeit tragen aber jetzt gibt es
das Internet das ist immer wieder wird
das diskutiert okay ich habe einen neuen
Namen bekommen vor drei Tagen Robert
ja finde ich auch total das war jetzt
neu finde ich gut dass man was anderes
passiert und
meine Musik soll das Ausschlaggebende
sein weißt du und nicht
wir heißt wir lebt wie seine Familie
aussieht ich möchte wirklich durch die
Musik definiert werden und das ist auch
das das ist mein Geschenk was ich den
Menschen geben kann ich sehe also ist
also ich sehe das so mein Privatleben
ist das Geschenk was ich mir behalten
will das ist etwas was ich brauche damit
ich meine Musik machen kann wenn ich
anfangen würde mein Privatleben in die
Öffentlichkeit zu tragen würde die Musik
darunter leiden weil ich nicht mehr
meinen Fluchtpunkt habe um mich
zurückziehen zu können um in Ruhe auch
mal Musik machen zu können das ist
einfach so die letzte rote Frage machen
wir danach das Finale kennst du die alle
auswendig ich weiß da weiß ich jetzt
welche übrig ist weil die passt
irgendwie
ich habe ganz ich habe ganz am Anfang
habe ich möge habe ich und das hat auch
geklappt alle Einträge entfernt also man
findet mich nicht im Telefonbuch und so
weiter über deinen Namen reden aber
jetzt ist er vorbei und ja ich musste
auch so Künstler Name aussuchen ja aber
der TV
ich bin der TV ich bin der TV okay
nächste Frage wann kommt endlich eine
home Story über dich in der Bild also
ich hoffe nie also solange ich das also
steuern kann werde ich versuchen das
niemals preiszugeben ne das ist wirklich
so
Anfragen kommen ohne Ende ja es kommen
ganz viele Anfragen wo natürlich die
Öffentlichkeit gar nichts von
mitbekommen weil wir die alle Absagen
aber
also der Graf wird irgendwann wenn der
Graf existiert so lange wie die Musik
existiert und wenn die Musik irgendwann
mal keiner mehr hören will dann kann ich
mich auch zurückziehen ne aber daran
denke ich jetzt nicht sondern ich möchte
gerne als Graf in der Öffentlichkeit
sein und das ist für mich eine Art
Schutzschild
vor allem was da auf mein Privatleben
einbrechen kann
auch so lange wie ich so darf echt ja
also es gibt mit Musik mit James Last
habe ich schon hatte ich schon fertig
aber noch nicht veröffentlicht diese
mein Schiff zwei Hymne die wird gar
nicht veröffentlicht das war nur für
diese das war nur für die Ping für die
große schiffstaufen und diese Platte
bekommst du auch nur an Bord und jedes
Mal wenn die Mein Schiff 2 ausläuft hört
man große Freiheit aus den Lautsprecher
nein also ich mache ich habe noch ganz
viel für wird es auch bis ich mache es
noch so lange die Knochen halten und so
lange meine Energie da ist und so lange
all das was ich in mir drin habe ich
habe da noch Spaß dran ich werde es auch
weitermachen wenn es mal was rüber wird
das ist auch vollkommen okay ich kann
nicht ohne Musik ich habe mein Leben
lang Musik gemacht okay dann wünsche ich
dir dass du das bis zum letzten Atemzug
weil das glaube ich wirklich schön dito
machen kannst du auch
wenn er jetzt noch mehr Fragen Lotto
sehen wollt dann kann ich nur das mit
dem Grafen von Unheilig aus dem letzten
Jahr empfehlen das ist wirklich sehr
tiefgehend es geht darum dass der Erfolg
sein Erfolg mit dem Tod eines Freundes
kam und ein weiteres sehr spannendes
fahren Leute ist das mit MoTrip seid
keine Hater und das erfolgreichste
Fragen oder was ist je gab ist das mit
Bushido mehr als eine Million weit ach
deutlich mehr als eine Million views
also haut rein bzw klickt an und
ansonsten bis dann